hello everyone this next game was
suggested to me by Muslim entirely on
Twitter saying that it's a crazy and
funny game played between two or two
rusty engines and by rusty he probably
means that they're not in the top three
engines in this championship even though
they would both crush any human player
in the world you don't know about TCC
it's the top chess engine championship
is its it has been played like a week
ago or something or a couple of days ago
even and Houdini won this championship
but now this this is the same
championship all only with rapid time
controls and so far after 17 rounds it's
stockfish actually in the lead followed
by Houdini this is a game from route
around 15 played between Texel 1.07 a 35
and bobcat 8 it's a very exciting game
and like I said I don't enjoy engine
games but one in 10,000 will be
interesting like this I guess and none
of the engines are allowed any opening
books so none of the engines knew any
openings during these games Knight to f3
by Texel and we have Knight to f6 and if
you're wondering why is there a photo of
a sheep Texel is obviously some sort of
a sheep I don't think Texel is anything
other than a type of sheep so so that's
why I put a photo of a sheep no no
special reason see for the English
opening Knight to c6 and d4 we have e 6
III now d5 Knight to c3 Bishop to d6
and c5 immediately Bishop to d7 now
Bishop to b5 Bishop to d7 and the bishop
captures on c6 immediately given up the
bishop pair b key actors on c6 and 935
and it seems like something you would
you would use in a bullet maybe in a
bullet game a bishop back to thee seven
now castles a5 stopping white from
pushing b4 we have Queen to b3 going
after the b7 pawn b6 now defending in c6
Bishop to c8
and this pawn on c6 is now beautiful
it's completely
completely paralyzing blacks queenside
Queen to c2
we have Bishop to a6 rook to d1 and
Bishop to b4 what ideas of maybe Bishop
capture c3 and pushing b5 so a for
stopping their idea Knight to e4 and
Knight captures on e4 d captures on e4
and Bishop to d2 and I know what you're
wondering why not capture this juicy
pawn on e4 well if Queen captures then
Bishop to e2 and you lose the exchange
although it's not that terrible for
white after something like Bishop to d2
Bishop captures rook captures Bishop
captures rook captures and castles
for example 97 and it seems like you
could white does have compensation for
the exchange and I don't know a human
probably wouldn't enjoy playing this
position with black but with the precise
play I think black should black should
prevail
so after D characters on e4 Bishop to b2
now Bishop captures rook captures and f6
Knight to d7 of course and the Bishop to
d3 attacking the Queen Queen d1 eyeing
that gg4 Square to go for g7 h5
preventing the Queen from coming to g4
and now comes rough captures on d3 white
Indian they decide to give up the
exchange but it was on its own terms
he captures Queen captures and rook to
h6 preventing win g6 check d5 now and
this is one happy engine this Texel
Queen to e7 and now comes the monster
move Knight captures on b6 we have seek
after some b6 and d5 so white first
sacrifice the exchange was rook after 73
now it sacrificed the whole piece with
nightcap or some b6 and currently in the
position white is down a whole rook but
there's a beautiful d6 and e 6 past c6
and d6 passed pawn and this will prove
to be quite the compensation Queen d8 we
have rook to d1 now and rogue back to h8
Queen to b5
with ideas of of pushing the pond to see
7g sex now and we have E for R up to c8
and it seems like black just the blunder
of the rook
what if white plays pawn to d6 check the
d7 check well king f7 and you can't
really capture because Queen captures
and the one would check you have to
block Queen captures King characters and
you lose the Queen and c8 and the game
so after up the c8 we have E 5 and D 5
is a spectacular move came to f7 was
played and what happens if you play
something like f5 well then rook the c1
and black is just doomed King to f7 for
example and now c7 if you move the Queen
and unfortunately you can't move the
Queen here but if you do then Queen d7
check King has to move Queen captures
and e6 now if you block with the Queen
you lose the rockin c8 so after King h7
simply b7 and it's a game over so after
c7 there is really no way to avoid
losing this game you can't you could
capture but that's just losing and you
can't play something like rock to f8
with ideas of if white captures then you
will capture the rock and c1 winning the
game because the white will capture the
Queen and bring of 90 Knight into the
game so promoting with Czech are very
nice under promotion so after E 5 black
decided to play king f7 blocking this
pawn rook to d3 now came back to f8 now
d7 rope to c7 and he captures on f6 you
can't capture back simply d8 Queen or
rope to f3 doesn't really matter
King to f7 not blocking the pawn again
h3 h4 and Queen captures on b6 rook to
h5 now be for a captures Queen captures
now white created another task pawn rook
to d5 rug captures he captures and now
Queen to d6
we have the D D for a 5d 3a 6d to now
Queen capture
sandy - and King captures on f6 and in
this moment when bobcat eight captured
the pawn on f6 decided it decided to
resign the game it seems like well black
doesn't really have a good move and but
it's interesting how does white win this
well the idea is that the blacks King is
simply too exposed so it's quite simple
to win this for example Queen d6 check
King f7 now Queen to c5 giving black the
move but preparing a7 King to e6 Queen
to e3 check for example King d6 if you
plucking the six queenie 8 wins
immediately you little grab the Queen or
Queen will grab Queen and then you get
another Queen with winning end game but
after Queen III check you don't have to
go King these six you can go king f7 for
example but now again a seven for
example g5 black doesn't really have
anything to play Queen b3 check King
East 7 Queen a3 check you move the king
and now eight you bring another Queen
into the game and it's game over
so yeah that's the game after King f6
Bobcat eight resigned the game and Texel
1.07 85 created this well a masterpiece
amongst engines I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and
just for the end I'm thinking about
making for example a Sunday or Saturday
day for subscribers games so I'm
interested to know would you be
interested to share in your own games
for example sending me a game but it has
to be a tournament game played in
classical time controls sending me a
game you know sharing a bit of a
background story about this game and
maybe a photo of you in your opponent's
so that's what I want to know what would
you be willing to share this for other
people to see and enjoy so yeah that's
it thank you for watching and I will see
you soon